Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Alessio Politi
Realizzare di essere molto fortunata,
è stato come accendere
la miccia del mio percorso.
È il 2014, e mi spediscono in Sud Sudan.
Il contesto umanitario per eccellenza.
Qui mi dicono, "Dai! così impari bene".
Là mi diranno:
"Guarda che mandano qui le prime missioni,
solo perché non sanno dire di no".
Ho 25 anni,
e per questo motivo
mi mandano in un ospedale
che Medici Senza Frontiere
gestisce da più di 20 anni,
così che io abbia il tempo
di capire e di imparare osservando.
Ma faccio solo in tempo a capire
che forse non sono
all'altezza del mio compito
che mi ritrovo su una barca
sul fiume Sobat,
in viaggio verso l'Etiopia
insieme ai miei colleghi,
per metterci in salvo.
Ma come?
Non ero io che ero andata
a salvare gli altri?
Era successo che la linea del fronte
dove le due etnie
del conflitto civile in corso,
i Dinka e i Nuer, si scontravano,
aveva fatto un improvviso balzo
in avanti verso l'ospedale.
E questo, per noi espatriati, era il segno
che il piano di evacuazione
si doveva mettere in atto
senza battere ciglio.
Sì, per noi espatriati:
quelli, ancora una volta, fortunati.
Mentre viaggiamo,
guardo sulla sponda del fiume
e sullo sfondo vedo i soldati ribelli
che vanno a combattere.
Sfrecciano su delle camionette malconce,
sparando in aria coi kalashnikov
per darsi la carica.
Be', tutto sommato quello me l'aspettavo:
ero partita per un Paese
in guerra da quasi mezzo secolo.
Ma che cos'è la guerra l'ho capito
solo quando ho visto in primo piano
una bambina di cinque anni, non di più,
che camminava
nella nostra stessa direzione.
Era una piccoletta vestita di stracci
che sembrava terribilmente sapere
quello che doveva fare.
Reggeva un fagotto e un bastone.
All'altro capo del bastone
si faceva guidare una vecchia:
la sua bisnonna, forse.
Cieca.
Camminavano per mettersi in salvo.
Gli uomini sullo sfondo
non erano altro che i mariti, i fratelli
e i padri delle due in primo piano.
E mentre penso, cala la notte.
Dopo poche settimane su suolo etiope,
mi ritrovo di nuovo in Sud Sudan
e mi mandano a riaprire la maternità
in un ospedale che poche settimane prima,
durante un attacco,
era stato raso al suolo
e dato alle fiamme.
Lavoro lì da qualche mese ormai,
e come spesso succede il walkie talkie
gracchia nella mia capanna.
Guardo fuori, ed è quasi l'alba.
Questo mi rallegra,
perché nonostante la giornata precedente
sono riuscita a dormire abbastanza.
Il suono gracchia,
quindi non colgo quello che dicono;
ma capisco che hanno bisogno di aiuto,
quindi mi incammino verso l'ospedale.
Sono solo tre minuti a piedi,
a passo normale;
ma quando li percorri,
lo fai così alla svelta,
e lasciando spazio all'immaginazione
su quello che troverai
aprendo la tenda della maternità
che in un attimo sei già lì.
Varco il cancello
sgangherato dell'ospedale,
e vedo due uomini che ne escono
reggendo una brandina,
tipo una rete metallica di un letto.
E capisco che la situazione che incontrerò
è un po', come sempre, ai limiti.
In Sud Sudan, la stragrande
maggioranza della gente
abita in capanne di fango e paglia,
nel bel mezzo del nulla.
Non ci sono strade asfaltate,
non c'è illuminazione elettrica.
Se sei abbastanza fortunato da avere
un ospedale funzionante vicino a te,
sai che almeno una ventina di chilometri
a piedi dovrai farteli.
Visto che, durante la notte,
solo la Via Lattea
può illuminarti il cammino
e durante la stagione delle piogge
diventa tutto un mare
di fango impraticabile,
se sei una donna,
e il tuo travaglio procede bene,
ti conviene partorire nella tua capanna.
Se invece c'è un problema,
c'è una complicanza,
devi iniziare a sperare
di essere fortunata,
devi avere la fortuna
che i tuoi cari capiscano
che c'è un problema
e decidano di portarti in ospedale,
e non dallo sciamano del villaggio.
Devi avere la fortuna
che la brandina famosa,
che è un bene di lusso
ed è condivisa nel villaggio,
sia libera e reperibile per te.
Ma soprattutto devi avere la fortuna
che la resistenza del tuo corpo,
e possibilmente anche quella
del bambino che porti in grembo,
siano più forti di tutte le avversità
che incontrerai lungo il cammino.
Insomma, entro in sala parto,
che è una stanza piccola
con due letti da parto abbastanza consunti
divisi da una tenda di plastica,
un lavandino e una mensola
con sopra i ferri del parto,
sterilizzati nell'autoclave a carbone.
L'ostetrica sud sudanese
mi ragguaglia sul caso:
è una donna in travaglio
del suo quarto figlio.
Le contrazioni sono regolari,
la dilatazione completa
e le spinte sono intense.
C'è un unico non trascurabile dettaglio,
che è la posizione del feto:
questo bambino non vuole nascere
di testa o di sedere, podalico,
ma vuole nascere di gomito, così.
Il mio cervello apre il tomo di ostetricia
studiato nella mia cara
Università di Monza,
che in quel momento mi sembra
anni luce lontana,
e la certezza è una sola:
il parto non è espletabile
per via naturale.
Serve un taglio cesareo urgente,
serve una sala operatoria,
degli strumenti appositi
e qualcuno che sappia fare l'intervento.
Però vi ricordate,
nell'ospedale dove sono
non c'è la sala operatoria
perché era stata bruciata
poco tempo prima.
So che se quella donna
non verrà operata presto,
a furia di contrarsi
il suo utero si romperà
e seguirà un'emorragia,
e lei morirà, in modo
più o meno rapido ma terribile.
Esattamente come era successo
a un'altra donna, proprio il giorno prima,
cosa che io non avevo ancora avuto
il tempo di rielaborare.
Insomma, il tempo è poco.
Quindi chiamo il capo villaggio,
e gli chiedo se può organizzare un volo
per trasferire la paziente in capitale.
Peccato che piove, e in Sud Sudan
un volo non si improvvisa così,
e non c'è niente che decolla
e niente che atterra su un mare di fango.
Do alla donna i pochi farmaci
che abbiamo a disposizione
per cercare di calmare le contrazioni,
anche se so che il travaglio di una donna
sa essere potente come un tornado
e non c'è farmaco che tenga.
Il battito cardiaco fetale
non si sente più.
C'è solo la donna a cui pensare, ora.
Passano tre ore,
che mi sembrano infinite,
finché la potenza di quel corpo di donna,
in un modo pressoché inspiegabile
all'ostetricia tradizionale,
riesce a modellare
quel corpo di figlio senza vita
e farlo passare nel canale
del parto, e darlo alla luce.
La donna è salva, è viva.
Io sono incredula, esausta
e molto sollevata.
Mi incammino verso la mia capanna,
e incontro Tito,
il capo villaggio sud sudanese,
un uomo alto, magro, senza un occhio
e con i denti davanti
ben separati, tipico dei Nuer.
Lui, in quanto capo villaggio,
sa già quello che è successo in sala parto
e si congratula con me.
Al che io cerco di chiarire,
e gli dico che io
non ho fatto un bel niente
e che la donna è stata
solo molto fortunata.
Gli dico: "She was just lucky".
Lui mi sorride e mi dice:
(Inglese) "La fortuna va bene.
Ileana, la fortuna va bene".
Il Sud Sudan mi resta nel cuore.
E nel 2016, quando
mi propongono di tornarci,
accetto senza neanche pensare.
Mi mandano in un enorme campo profughi,
a 130 chilometri a nord
dal posto dove ero stata
nella prima missione.
E lì ho di nuovo una grande fortuna.
Incontro alcuni dei colleghi sud sudanesi
con cui avevo già lavorato l'altra volta.
Sono troppo felice di ritrovarli,
vivi.
Tra un parto e l'altro mi raccontano
del perché sono dovuti scappare,
e del come l'hanno fatto;
e visto che le rappresaglie
si intensificavano al calare del sole,
la gente che scappava
doveva avanzare durante il giorno
e nascondersi nelle paludi
durante la notte.
Dovevano passare la notte
con in braccio i bambini,
perché il fango arrivava alla loro vita.
Roda è una ostetrica molto in gamba,
oltre che di una bellezza unica.
E mi racconta delle donne
che si mettevano in travaglio
durante quelle nottate,
e dei parti assistiti con il nulla,
dei cordoni ombelicali
tagliati con i pezzi di lamiera.
E c'è un parto nello specifico,
il cui ricordo è come
se non la lasciasse tranquilla.
Continua a ripetermi le manovre
che ha fatto per salvare i bambini,
perché era un parto gemellare,
come per cercare la mia approvazione.
Al che io le dico che è stata una grande
e che per quella madre, e quei bambini,
lei è stata un vero dono di vita,
e che sono stati fortunati.
E penso di nuovo al "Lucky is good".
Questa e mille altre storie
mi fanno pensare
che i nostri colleghi locali
sono i veri eroi.
Nonostante siano loro,
le prime vittime della guerra,
hanno la forza di venire
a lavorare con noi di giorno e di notte
per prendersi cura dei nostri pazienti.
Seppur traumatizzati,
hanno la forza di venire
e lenire il trauma della loro gente.
È come se sapessero mettere in pausa
il ricordo degli orrori
che vivono ogni giorno -
dei parenti, degli amici ammazzati,
degli stupri, della fame -
per venire a prendersi cura
dei nostri pazienti,
che sono a volte i loro nemici.
Quando, nel 2017,
abbiamo aperto una maternità
nel Kurdistan iracheno,
a pochi chilometri
da dove si svolgeva la battaglia
per la liberazione di Mosul dall'Isis,
trovare delle ostetriche
disposte a venir a lavorare
insieme a noi vicino al fronte
è stato quasi impossibile.
Perché tutte avevano paura, giustamente.
Finalmente riesco a mettere insieme
un team molto eterogeneo,
un mix di curde, di irachene,
di yazidi, di siriane.
E se pensate alla storia
di tutti questi popoli,
vi sembrerà impossibile.
Eppure loro lavoravano insieme,
in sala parto, in prima linea
per prendersi cura di altre donne,
stremate dalla guerra.
Passa un anno, e come ostetrica
sono molto entusiasta,
perché mi propongono di andare
in una delle più grandi
maternità del mondo,
a Khost, in Afghanistan.
Parlo di una vera e propria
"fabbrica di bambini",
che ne sforna più di 23.000 all'anno.
Che sono una sessantina,
in media, al giorno:
ma alle volte anche un centinaio.
Sono numeri da far girare la testa,
che non mi sembrano possibili
neanche dopo esserci stata.
Qui in Italia, se assisti
tre parti in una notte,
sei autorizzata a sentirti tosta.
Là ricordo le ostetriche afghane
letteralmente collassate a terra,
dopo un turno di 14 ore di notte,
in quel caos dove due o tre donne
travagliavano nello stesso letto.
Una realtà ai limiti,
dove la vita nasce e dove la vita resiste,
Un po' come per Bibi, che partorisce
la sua quarta figlia sulle montagne,
e arriva da noi che è incosciente,
in shock emorragico, è quasi morta.
Per provare a salvarla,
non ci resta che volare in sala operatoria
e toglierle l'utero.
Per farlo, però, abbiamo bisogno
del permesso del marito
che non è sempre una cosa
facile da ottenere.
Quindi corro da lui,
insieme all'interprete,
e parto già un po' prevenuta,
come pronta a doverlo convincere
usando del tempo
che in quegli attimi non c'è.
Invece mi trovo davanti
un uomo di montagna,
con la pelle bruciata dal sole
e la barba lunga.
Mi sembra un povero tra i poveri,
che mi ascolta attento.
Forse non coglie tutto quello che dico,
ma capisce che non gli resta
che darci piena fiducia
e appone l'impronta digitale
sul foglio del consenso informato,
perché non sa firmare.
In Afghanistan non mi è neanche permesso
di guardare un uomo negli occhi,
però io lo vorrei abbracciare.
Sotto i ferri, il cuore di Bibi si ferma
non una, ma ben due volte, e poi riparte.
Cosa quasi inverosimile, con gli strumenti
che abbiamo a nostra disposizione.
La situazione è estremamente critica:
però l'intervento termina
e Bibi è ancora viva.
Durante la notte, però,
la situazione degenera di nuovo:
il suo sangue è come impazzito,
non coagula più.
Quindi non ci resta
che tornare in sala operatoria,
riempire la sua pancia di garze
per cercare di fermare il sanguinamento,
richiuderla e stare a vedere.
E così facciamo.
Passano due giorni
e la situazione sembra tenere,
quindi ci prepariamo
per tornare in sala operatoria
e togliere quelle garze,
che sembra abbiano fatto il loro lavoro.
Quindi ci riprepariamo di nuovo.
Siamo tutti molto tesi,
lavoriamo in modo silenzioso e preciso.
Ed è proprio Bibi a rompere quel silenzio,
perché ci guarda, in pashtun dice:
"State tranquilli, che io ce la faccio".
E così succede:
dopo tre settimane Bibi se ne torna
sulle sue montagne, con la sua bambina,
ed è piena di vita.
(Inglese) - "È stata fortunata"
- "La fortuna va bene"
Fortuna e vita,
Vita e fortuna a braccetto.
Quella fortuna che io ho avuto,
e realizzare di averla mi ha fatto vibrare
e mi ha spinto lontano
per cercare di restituirla.
Quella fortuna che ho visto essere
l'ago della bilancia
tra la morte e la vita.
Quella vita che va onorata e apprezzata,
cercando quello che ci fa vibrare.
E a voi, che cosa vi fa sentire vivi?
Che cosa vi fa vibrare?
(Applausi)